sur twitter après avoir entendu les
différentes réactions et les réactions
en particulier les réactions politiques
aux annonces du président de la
république car dès hier soir deux camps
sont apparus dans le champ politique
d'un côté il y a ceux qui approuvent
chaudement ces mesures c'est bien sûr
notamment le cas à la république en
marche de christophe castaner
le choix qui est proposée par le
président de la république c'est un
choix de liberté celui de se vacciner ou
pas mais celui aussi dès lors qu'on ne
se vaccinent pas et qu'on est prêt à
s'exposer à un risque de au fond assumé
de se priver d'un certain nombre de
lieux mais le choix de la liberté c'est
faire en sorte que toutes celles et tous
ceux qui parce que l'état a mis en place
tous les dispositifs qui le permettent
soit vacciné et puissent du coup accéder
dans les différents lieux et c'est aussi
le point de vue dans l'opposition du
député l air de l'yonne guillaume
larrivé qui dit sur twitter c'est pour
libérer nos vies de ce satané virus que
nous devons sans tarder étendre
l'obligation vaccinale et le pass
sanitaire je prendrai ma part de
responsabilité comme député en votant
pour ce projet de loi nécessaire il ya
d'ailleurs une divergence chez dlr par
exemple le vice président gilles platret
qui est contre notamment en remet de
façon générale on voit que c'est plutôt
en phase que se mobilisent les
oppositions dans les partis on va
revenir avec vous dominique rey des
contestataires
d'abord côté rn je vous propose
d'écouter le porte-parole laurent jacoby
on voit bien qu'il va y avoir une
fracture sanitaire entre ceux qui
pourront se payer des tests pcr est ce
qu'ils seront contraints de se vacciner
parce qu'ils ne pourront pas se payer
des tests emmanuel macron ce soir a
inventé un concept qui est la violence
tranquille il a eu un discours d'une
violence historique
le tout avec un ton posé un peu
satisfait comme il le fait
habituellement sans régler aucun
problème sanitaire autres indignation
dénonciation celle de député la france
insoumise de seine-saint-denis eric
coquerel
ce soir le président de la république où
je peux dire c'est le président candidat
à la prison l'agly parce que les deux se
mélangent et un peu montre que nous
propose finalement une société du
contrôle et de la régression sociale
généralisée
la question du vaccin obligatoire et
véritable ur une question qui mérite
déposés et qui dit obligations du
contrôle donc robail contrôler en
permanence
on va être contrôlée en permanence
d'abord est-ce que vous approuvez en
tout cas c'est le point de vue de
monsieur cochrane est ce que vous
approuvez d'abord les mesures du
président de la république jean
moi j'aurais préféré qu'il fasse
vraiment le choix de la liberté et qu'il
adopte par exemple la stratégie mise en
place par boris johnson
au royaume uni c'est à dire de dire
finalement vaccinons et finalement
ouvrons ouvrons tout et vaccinons et
tant pis pour les non vaccinés ce sont
eux effectivement ils prennent le risque
et si ici se retrouve à l'hôpital à la
limite tant pis pour eux on les soignera
mais bon on l'est seront laisse ouvert
je pense que c'était le vrai pari de la
liberté cela dit georges entend aussi
l'argument que au royaume uni on est à
50 % de taux de couverture vaccinale
c'est là que les gens ont joué le jeu se
sont fait vacciner alors qu'en france on
était encore à 36% 37% de deux doses
donc effectivement il y avait un blocage
et je suis assez partagé parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait en france
malheureusement on doit toujours passer
par la contrainte par par une forme de
contrainte détourner l' on peut assumer
ce qui est ce qu'a fait le président un
public à une forme de notes vous savez
cette stratégie marketing qui n'est pas
une contrainte une obligation direct par
la loi mais qui finalement une forme
d'incitation des tournées on pousse
finalement et ça a très bien marché
puisque on a vu qu'il hier les demandes
de réservations vaccin sur d'octo libre
absolument exploser notamment beaucoup
de jeunes qui avaient envie de profiter
de l'arrêter et qui se sont précipités
vers les demandes de rendez vous donc ça
a fonctionné
moi je trouve toujours dommage d'en
arriver là mais j'ai des responsabilités
partagées parce que le peuple français
n'a pas joué le jeu aussi de l'aide de
la vaccination
votre point de vue demi mois je je
trouve que les
les deux représentants des partis la
france insoumise et rennes qu'on a
entendues sont les deux seuls qui n'ont
pas la possibilité de dire ce qu'ils ont
dit au fond ce sont des libéraux qui
pourrait dire ça on a en france un
système qui est très socialiser qui
collectiviste quasiment matière de santé
la conséquence de cela c'est que quand
quelqu'un se vaccinent pas il n'en subit
pas le coût 8 seul puisque le coût est
collectiviser et donc si on est pour la
liberté de ne pas sa vaccination faut
qu'on soit pour la privatisation des
systèmes d'assurance sociale ou là
effectivement j'aurai le choix de
négocier avec mon assureur
mais ma liberté de me vacciner ou pas
c'est une société comme celle là qui
peut être qu'il ya de l'intérêt
mais là quand on a la critique depuis
ceux qui considèrent que ce soit le rn
où la france a soumis ce que ne sont pas
ces socialiser en particulier dans le
domaine de la santé ça veut dire que
tout risque qui est pris par un individu
et un risque couru par toute la
communauté
eh bien ça comme conséquence
l'obligation de se vacciner c'est le
modèle social défendu par coquerelles et
le porte parole du rnd qui est très
proche c'est ce modèle social qui dure
boudé le français quasiment qui conduit
à l'obligation de vacciner parce que oui
alors ce que voulait dire voilà ce que
voulait dire par là c'est que finalement
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles nous
vacciner on va recourir à cette
obligation en tous les cas cette
contrainte vaccinale c'est pour éviter
la thrombose dans l'est dans les
hôpitaux c'est pour éviter une surcharge
en tous les cas de notre système de
remboursement social sera sa route c'est
pour éviter l'effondrement
du système sanitaire et du système
économique on peut pas dans un système
collectiviser encore une fois on peut
pas dire les tests sont gratuits la
vaccination n'est pas obligatoire
on sort quand on veut on va où on veut
moi je trouve ça moi je suis libéral
donc je trouve qu'il faudrait qu'on
puisse décider dans la liberté et en
assumer la responsabilité
mais dans un système où ce que vous
décidez est payé par les autres où le
risque que vous prenez est courue par
les autres ça ne marche pas et là nous
aurions à la fois une épidémie qui n'en
finirait pas un système qui serait de
plus en plus coûteux et on dirait mais
j'ai ma liberté mais tokyo n'a le coup
ça ne tient pas du tout même moralement
je dirais ça ne tient pas le coup n'est
cela dit moi je trouve que le faire le
pas sanitaire tel qu'il a été présenté
par emmanuel macron est extrêmement
large et trop larges
chatel qui les a présentés hier
notamment fait les enfants de plus de 12
ans et les mineurs je sois je pense que
c'est complètement exagéré que en fait
finalement on veut atteindre un taux de
limiter collectif qui à 80% et comme moi
on sait qu'on n'arrivera pas à
convaincre 20% de dante ivax acharné
bien on va chercher chez les jeunes et
donc on descend finalement la barre en
dessous des en dessous des mineurs pour
aller chercher pour vacciner des enfants
pour finalement atteindre ce taux
d'immunité et je trouve que c'est que
c'est dommage de faire payer ça aux
jeunes et je ne comprends pas pourquoi
alors pour quelles raisons légales mais
je
j'aimerais que les juristes m'expliquer
pourquoi on n'a pas obligé
spécifiquement les personnes fragiles et
les vieux à se faire vacciner
on a fait le même choix pendant le
confinement c'est-à-dire de confiner
tout le monde plutôt que confiné les
personnes fragiles là on dit on vaccine
tout le monde peut que les vagues que
les personnes fragiles et en france on a
un vrai problème c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'on a encore un taux de personnes
fragiles ou avec des commandos n'y était
que deux personnes qui sont pas vaccinés
qui refusent sur l'axé neigeux
comprendre qu'on n'a pas ciblé d'abord
ses personnages alors est ce que c'est à
cause du grand principe d'universalité
française la volonté ne pas discriminer
ne pas faire de campagne ciblée oui mais
moi je vois la sphère discrimination 2
de fait oui mais on l'a fait entre non
vaccinés et vaccinés mais je pense que
d'abord une première étape aurait été
aurait dû être d'obliger à la
vaccination les personnes fragiles
celles qui peuvent contracter des formes
graves de la maladie et précisément à l
hôpital se soit pas les personnes entre
12 et 18 ans qui vont aller à l'hôpital
et qui vont faire payer à la
collectivité leur maladie en même temps
moi ce qui m'a étonné là encore dans les
réactions qu'on a entendu une fraction
de la vaccination
j'ai l'impression qu'on découvre dans ce
pays qui a des vaccinations obligatoires
parce que c'est pas nouveau il ya des
tas de vaccination obligatoire 11
oxydation voilà et chacun sait que la
pulsion d'agnès musée
oui et puis intérieurement ça existait 3
c'est une une antienne donc c'est pas
quelque chose si vous voulez le le point
là aujourd'hui c'est on ne voit pas
comment sortir de là de la pandémie moi
je n'arrive pas à comprendre comment te
sortent de la pandémie si on prend pas
des mesures qui ramène les individus à
leur rationalité économique donc vous
pour les risques vous allez payer ou à
une obligation puisque la région et
économique débat recevable j'imagine que
ce n'est pas recevable déjà quand on dit
vous allez payer et spcr les gens
protestent comme si c'était naturel de
ne pas payer la teste cela dit moi je
pense maintenant que le passé militaire
a été actée est lancé qui doit voir une
contrepartie très forte qui la levée de
toutes les restrictions et de et
d'arrêter de d'agiter des perspectives
de reconfirmer comme le font certains
médecins confie nist qui adore agité les
variants pour vouloir nous re confiné où
nous obliger à porter le masque masque
en extérieur comme ça a été fait dans
plusieurs municipalités balnéaire ce qui
est une absurdité sanitaires et qui en
plus décourage la vaccination parce que
si même quand vous vacciner vous devez
continuer à porter le masque continuer à
avoir des restrictions en tous sens ça
ne pousse pas ça n'encourage pas la
vaccination je pense que la contrepartie
de ce passé à lithaire ça va être la
levée de toutes les restrictions et un
engagement ferme du gouvernement qui
doit dire eux nous faisons pas de
sanitaires mais nous ne leur confie ne
rompt pas nous ne céderons pas à la peur
parce que c'est bien beau d'agiter de
dire que les errances ivax jouent sur la
peur mais il y en a aussi il ya du côté
des confiseurs et des médecins qui adore
agité aussi ce climat anxiogène et moi
personnellement je suis rétive à cette
rhétorique de la peur dans les deux sens
c'est pour ça que je suis très hostile
au confinement et
il est favorable à la vaccination mais
je trouve qu'il faut aller dans les deux
sens ou par non pas ne pas donner de
contrepartie parce que sinon les gens ne
vont pas comprendre pourquoi à quoi bon
de se faire vacciner
dominique est ce que le jeu revient
justement sur les sur ces partis
contestataires que on a entendu
et puis également il ya les pros mâcon
20 de l'école et les pros vaccins qu'on
a entendu également un autre un autre
bloc qui fait jour est-ce que mais est
ce que le parti contestataire qui est de
façon générale en recul voire chaos
après les régionales n'a pas là un moyen
de se refaire j'en profite d'ailleurs
pour souligner deux études race récente
et passionnante que vous avez fait sur
le sujet d'abord la protestation
électorale en 2021 qui est une analyse
des élections régionales et c'est
absolument passionnant et 2022 le risque
populiste en france avec ça c'est une
étude que vous faites au long cours et
la dernière vague qui date de juin
alors cette fois ci avant sans doute les
élections régionales c'était avril
c'était eva avant les actions j'ai en
effet se trouve tout à fait
volontairement ils ont contrés par une
cinquième vague pour la rentrée j'hésite
à parler de vague de vagues électorale
absolument non et on regarde le sens de
l'humour voilà maintenant non mais c'est
si vrai ça d'abord juste une remarque
comme moi je suis pas certain que le rn
soit dans les choux
il a quand même obtenu 20% des suffrages
exprimés dans ce désert électorale qu'on
était les régionales ça c'est un premier
point c'est pas si mal
et puis ensuite il ya de bonnes raisons
de penser que l'abstention est massive
parce qu'elle est protestataires et que
donc c'est 1-0 le sait et c'est
principalement les électeurs l'électorat
du fn qui étaient touchés par
l'abstention
donc ce sont des électeurs qui vont pas
rester dans l'abstention on avait
presque 31 millions d'abstentionnistes
il y en avait 12 millions et demi au
second tour en 2010 est donc on va avoir
probablement une vingtaine de millions
qui vont venir voter à la présidentielle
où ça va être dans cette roja
vous imaginez ces 20 millions qui vont
débarquer est ce que c'est pour dire
leur contentement leur satisfaction
ou est ce que c'est pour exprimer une
protestation sachant que là dedans il ya
la plupart des électeurs de marine le
pen
quelqu'un de mélenchon sans doute qu'il
va y avoir une sacrée secousses en 2022
parce que les eaux de la protestation
vont voir remonter
je voulais savoir est-ce que c'est
complètement tirée par les cheveux ou
bien est ce que on peut en tout cas
établi un lien ou établir une hypothèse
entre peut-être certains qui refusent la
vaccination ce qu'on va voir justement
de quelle proportion ça représente et
une partie de ces abstentionnistes
oui c'est ce sont des figures
aujourd'hui polymorphe de la
protestation de l'antipolitique de
lentilles système qui prennent toutes
sortes d'expressions pêle mêle ça peut
aller pour certaines du vote à rennes au
vote
la france est soumise aux à dist aux
anti vaccins au gilet jaune
il ya une grande variété ya quand même
44 % de français qui gardent une
sympathie à l'égard exactement c'est
grosso modo quasiment la moitié donc ça
c'est colossal et c'est pareil c'est une
braise toujours là qui prépare là aussi
une expression électorale qui peut être
l'abstention y compris à la
présidentielle si la protestation va
jusqu'à rejeter la l'élection clé du
système et qui peut se trouver un
passage pour hacker le système je me
mets moi je crois que ce qui me frappe
beaucoup dans cette épidémie c'est la
politisation de la science et du rapport
les vaccins les masques des objets qui
est a priori et il y avait un débat
scientifique sur leur utilité mais qui
était qu'ils sont a priori neutres sont
devenue politisée et on parce qu il y
aussi des mensonges d'aidé aux missions
etc qui ont conduit à sa mort aux
etats-unis c'est très frappant le masque
était devenu pendant la campagne
présidentielle américaine un un symbole
politique c'est à vous porter un masque
vous étiez un démocrate ou n'emportait
pas vous étiez un républicain je ne sais
pas dire c'est la même division sur le
vaccin sachant que trump a beaucoup
poussé pour le vaccin aux états unis
mais nous en france un peu le mas avait
pas d'engin comme l'huître wii et sur le
sur le mets sur le vaccin voilà une
dimension politique et une crise talion
enfin autour de la personne de macron
c'est à dire que c'est même plus le
débat n'est plus sur l'efficacité ou pas
du vaccin c'est
à roger deneys macron de ski de ce qu'il
s'est passé les metteurs en fait les cas
c'est parce que c'est le maquereau nisme
c'est en marche c'est emmanuel macron
qui dit il faut se faire vacciner que
l'émetteur et une telle défiance
politique que le vaccin et gérer parce
que la défiance vaccinale est le produit
de la défiance politique et non pas
l'inversé
la médecine c'est de la politique et je
fais juste une référence rapide parce
qu'elle est connue de nous tous mais
c'est cette extraordinaire à relire
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
c'est à la fois plaisant et profond que
noc
c'est une pièce sur la médecine qui a
pris le pouvoir c'est une pièce sur le
caractère politique des décisions
médicales et sur l'effet de contrôle que
la médecine se produit dans une société
dont elle s'occupe
c'est vraiment tout à fait bluey sens je
suppose d'ailleurs que c'est un livre
qui a gelé jamais vérifié qui a dû
influencer beaucoup michel foucault
parce que son travail ensuite sur la
médecine bien pouvoir est tout à fait
dans cette instance est continuation la
de cette inspiration première à d'avis
sur la question puisque vous traitez
michel foucault dans votre dernier livre
oui oui non mais tout à fait mais moi je
suis frappée à quel point effectivement
bien il ya un clivage enfin la fracture
vaccinale recouvre un clivage politique
et un clivage social et pas seulement
une opinion sur la vaccination c'est
beaucoup plus large que ça et c'est
effectivement cette défiance l'axé
creuset qui le fruit d'années et
d'années de d'errements politique elle
se résoudra pas en un jour et
aujourd'hui c'est juste l'une des
manifestations de cette crise la
confiance trahie les a confiance on va
on va y revenir
est ce que au delà de la problématique
sanitaire emmanuel macron n'a pas aussi
voulu répondre à des aspirations dans le
10 sport qu'il a fait dans la rhétorique
qu'il a fait dans la gestuelle qu'il a
eue dans le décorum qui avait à des
aspirations vous avez identifié dans
démocratie sous tension j'en ai retrouvé
certaines il existe dites-vous une
demande d'autorité les sociétés
démocratiques préfère plus l'ordre même
si là cela entraîne moins de l'ibère
absolument absolument c'est ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on mesure constamment
depuis quelques années dans nos travaux
à la fondation pour l'innovation côté
qui sont en ligne gratuitement je le
dirai pas parce que on ne vend pas cc
c'est une scène trad et il y avait dans
la phase antérieure au discours du
président hier il y avait un début d
exaspération quand on partait de la
population parce qu'on n'en sort pas de
telles gt ça on n'en sort pas maintenant
on nous indique qu'il ya de moins en
moins de personnes qui vont se faire
vacciner qui à des doses en stock on ne
sait pas quoi en faire et que l'on va
pas en sortir parce qu'il ya pas assez d
vacciner mais qu'attend donc le
président pour taper du poing sur la
table et dire maintenant c'est
obligatoire je crois que s'il n'avait
pas fait il allait avoir ce aurait été
atteint le coeur de ce qu'il reste de sa
de sa position aujourd'hui le coeur le
coeur est essentiel c'est la position
d'autorité et de au fond d'eux de
souveraineté au sens où le pouvoir qui
n'a pas de supérieur si vous voulez je
pense qui est l'essence de la semaine
absolument c'est la définition même
exactement
et donc là il y là je pense repris là
dessus la main et sans doute aussi parce
que c'est une des sept cdc dans le
contexte dans lequel nous nous trouvons
sans doute aussi at il empêché par cette
parole
la renaissance en tout cas à court terme
d'une droite d'autorité qui aurait mené
plus aisément campagne c'est on est un
petit côté je suis je suis quand même le
chef c'est le fait le quatrième
anniversaire de ceux de ce discours du
13 juillet 2007
on sent qu'il veut c'est d'ailleurs chez
les anti pacs qui sont sûrement dans les
parties parfois extrêmes qui sont dans
une demande d'autorité par ailleurs sono
sujets régaliens sur ce sujet et réclame
une liberté et critique la dictature
sanitaires etc
donc elle aussi un paradoxe mais à
linverse aussi
la demande autorités on voit qu'elle
s'exerce assez facilement en matières
satinées t on à pu continuer sans
problème
quand il s'agissait de contrôler des
vieilles dames qui avaient pas leur
attestation les policiers était
inflexible
par contre dans les domaines que vous
connaissez bien de lutter contre le
front des frontières migratoire de
sécurité que l'impuissance de l'état est
absolument accablante et déclaré
voeckler
je pense qu'il va y avoir un hiatus dans
l'est dans les mois et les années à
venir parce qu'on va dire écoutez
attendait pour obliger la vaccination il
n'y a pas de problème pour confiner n'y
a pas de problème mais par contre quand
on sait que c'est impossible donc
peut-être que d'ailleurs ça va être un
déclic
quelque part et qu'on va dire ben enfin
enfin ce qu'on croyait impossible c'est
à dire contrôler les frontières mais der
des mesures assez restrictive que moi je
me souviens des débats d'un soutien
canal nicolas sarkozy quand il
s'agissait de faire des contrôles au ce
chez les mineures pour dt pour des
migrants pour déterminer leur âge la
gauche veut pousser des cris d'orfraie
en disant en rappelant le vichy et le
troisième reich
peut-être que là le débat va être un peu
à peu différent à tenir parce que enfin
il ya quand même on peut pas on peut pas
dire du conséquences et sanitaires on a
tous les pouvoirs
et puis décrété l'impuissance en matière
de contrôle des frontières non ça c'est
un enjeu clé j'ai tout à fait d'accord
la politique sanitaire face à une
pandémie
une pandémie qui probablement va durer
assez longtemps oblige à une
reconfiguration de la politique dans son
ensemble de l'autorité de sa forme et il
y a un lien direct avec le contrôle la
surveillance d'ailleurs c'est assez
problématique pour nos sociétés y
compris la surveillance et le contrôle
du territoire
évidemment les français ne
comprendraient pas qu'après tous ses
efforts ou et ses obligations en
puissance vraiment de la question autour
des frontières et voilà ce que disait je
n'imagine qu'on puisse rentrer comme on
veut éventuellement doivent rejoindre
pays est ce qu'il ya dans ce que vous
mesurez est ce qu'il ya eu un sentiment
d'injustice on sait qui s'est exprimé de
la manière qu'ils se qui s'exprimeraient
de la manière suivante on n'a pas
contrôler les frontières par contre on
les a on était obligés de nous mettre
des frontières chez nous avec le
confinement qui étymologiquement
l'établissement de santé absolument
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas encore
je dirai tout à fait formalisé mais qui
va venir
inévitablement si par des manifestations
je dirais autour de faits divers ou
d'événements rapportés il est établi ou
visibles que les français l'éprouvant
toute façon que les mouvements
migratoires sont hors de contrôle ou
très mal contrôlée et que là il ya une
sorte de liberté absolue de la liberté
de style trois libéraux eux je dirais
tandis que les français citoyens
français de ce pays ils sont sont
assignés à résidence ou à des
obligations al'inverse est ce que le
libéralisme n'a pas montré dans ce débat
également ses contradictions
plus tôt on a plutôt l'expression
majoritaire d'un libéralisme mais qui
est un attachement au bien-être
économique avant d'être un attachement
aux libertés
moi je vois le débat qui fait rage entre
olivier babeau d'un côté fondation
sapiens qui réclame une vaccination
obligatoire pour retrouver la vie
économique et d'un autre côté des gens
comme mathieu slama autre libéral qui
s'indignent des états des atteintes aux
libertés publiques
on peut citer d'ailleurs à ce sujet la
présidente de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée la députée lrm yaël boon
privé brawn piger qui déclarait sur
france 5 on va le voir en tweets qui se
vantait au sujet du passé sanitaires
justement il ya qui a environ donc le 13
mai dernier j'ai tenu inscrire noir sur
blanc dans la loi qu'un restaurant au
cinéma ou un théâtre ne pourra pas
l'exiger c'est une question de libertés
publiques
et si ya pas justement la fracture au
sein du monde libéral bas après ccc
définition que donne la liberté la
liberté c'est pas un bien personnel dont
je suis le seul à jouir et tant pis pour
les autres
personne n'a envie certains libéraux
vous opposeront 7 des classes est cette
définition et par moi je ne trouve pas
recevable ce que je lis là je trouve pas
ça recevoir
en angleterre à la fin du 18ème siècle
sur les lois sur les prostituées
s'appelait le 10/10 actes dans lequel je
ne suis jeune chance mais il a été
impliqué où il s'agissait en fait
d'obliger les prostituées à faire des
contrôles pour voir si elles avaient des
maladies vénériennes
le but affiché était de débarrasser la
population de ces maladies vénériennes
qui était qui ce qui se transmettaient
en soumettant ses prostituées à des
contrôles et il ya un grand débat entre
les numéros entre ceux qui disent eh ben
non la liberté individuelle est d'abord
enfin ccvo d'abord et ceux qui disaient
non il faut pour le bien-être collectif
et c'est un débat qu'on retrouve
exactement aujourd'hui c'est à dire est
ce que ce qui doit primer c'est
l'intérêt la collectivité en en écrasant
sadani berthet individuel ou est-ce que
ou est-ce que celle ci devait être sacré
je crois que c'est une tension qui est
consubstantielle à mon avis au
libéralisme et ce qu'ils appellent
justement un tournant puisque c'était
cette conception des libertés
individuelles qui primait jusqu'à
présent sur le primat des libertés
collectives
enfin on vit dans un pays ultra
collectiviste je suis désolé ça n'existe
pas en france le libéralisme de fait
nous avons une étrange liberté nous
avons la liberté de faire ce que nous
voulons est la possibilité de socialiser
les conséquences réellement c'est
intenable réellement ça ne tient pas le
système est incohérent et donc on ne
sait pas en france ce que c'est que la
liberté réelle c'est à dire je prends
mes risques et j'en assume les
conséquences nous on prend un but un
risque on en fait assumer à conséquent
soit ça ne tient pas et donc on n'est
pas tout à fait concernée je dirais par
ce débat là qu est un débat plus
américains que français
on a eu quand même passion tidiane les
lecteurs il a du figaro en tous les cas
état est un débat qui remonte en ce
moment puisque vous avez quand même vu
des contestataires qui redécouvre ces
notions là je voudrais donner la parole
à nos internautes merci en tous les cas
d'avoir justement débattre sereinement
et le débat s'est un peu racheté rejette
donc on reste calme qui me calmer on
continue de débattre on est là justement
pour débattre on va vous donner la
parole oui nathan je vous donne ma
parole on me demande de ne pas venir à
une fête familiale parce que non
vaccinés ça s'annonce merveilleux
le monde d'après je vous recommande un
tweet d'ailleurs de génie qui est assez
drôle qui reprend le dessin en amande
affaire dreyfus
on n'est pas obligé de se faire vacciner
il peut faire un test pcr
voilà donc que pour l'instant c'est le
passé ni terre et même pas forcément
pour aller à la fête familiale mon point
de vue nous dit ouais bof run c'est que
macron m'impose une injection que je
refuse catégoriquement et me prive de
mes libertés nicole annoncé le 12
juillet le pass pour des bus ou dans les
centres commerciaux resto et autres et
scandaleux alors on va voir
c'est un petit peu compliqué au niveau
de la mise en place d'après ce que même
de l'aveu même de jean castex cet après
midi à l'assemblée je suis révolté aussi
de ces annonces nous dit pas tout
patrice alors ce qui est intéressant si
le point de vue de nicole également j'ai
le vaccin complet mais je refuse de
présenter à laisser passer pour aller au
resto ou faire des courses et nathan une
petite majorité est en train d'écraser
une grosse minorité on va y revenir
justement nathan en parlant de la
question des retraites
la petite majorité c'est plutôt la
grosse majorité et kris kross nous dit
pas de guerre civile à base de fusil
mais une énorme tension dans la société
al'inverse alain naudy l'application
vaccinale est un élément de solidarité
on vous posait la question
les annonces des manuels macron sur la
vaccination le passé ni terre dont elle
crée de nouvelles fractures au sein de
la société française et vous êtes
pessimiste vous dit oui à 74%
il ya un sondage qui sort avec le figaro
ce soir dans une mineure aux docks celle
d'axa qui dit que 67% des français
approuve les mesures d' emmanuel macron
donc une plus de deux tiers des français
donc effectivement
ça je ne sais pas ça veut dire que c'est
une autre cas c'est plus la minorité
plutôt du côté des ambitions de ceux qui
sont en mesure d manueel macron alors
parmi les mesures les annonces des mânes
de macron